i look at social media as initially
being very dopaminergic it's just like
gambling driving rewards surprise and
excitement but very quickly
transitioning to something more like ocd
so you're scrolling you're scrolling and
then you see something so if you're
reading some interesting things this
came out in the news and then it's all
of a sudden a riot or a person that is
based jumping off a building but look if
something's very tragic then that has
this gravitational pull and then what
happens is you start getting the system
working for that next dopamine hit that
you don't know when it's gonna if we
were to look at ourselves through the
lens of an experiment like we would an
animal experiment we think that animal
is sick if you saw an animal digging in
the corner looking looking looking
looking for a bone the dog you'd think
that's really sad that's us